CARTER MORGAN: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a new series
where we explain the
ins and outs of securing
your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode,
you'll learn about the third of
three distinct areas of cloud
security risk.
The platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE DIALS]
BRAD ACTOR: Hello,
Cloud detective.
You may have understood
securing access and data,
but what about the platform?
What makes the physical
and virtual hardware
Google provides secure?
Once your data is
in the cloud, how
do you know it's really safe?
What if VMs aren't
being properly isolated
from other workloads, leading
to a tricky tenants isolation
exploit?
Are the physical devices being
properly secured and checked
for malware?
What about people at Google
looking at your data?
What if one of my hench people
gets into a Google data center?
For your sake, I hope you know
the answer to my questions.
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
here's what we know.
Platform represents the physical
systems that house and deliver
information.
It's important to understand
the abstract notion of a user
accessing information is
realized in physical systems,
and the sum total of those
systems is the platform.
We often think of the platform
as a server side thing
but really, it's everything
from the user's fingertips,
to the bit on the
disk, the in between,
the server which runs
applications, and so on.
But since we have a
shared security model,
it's important to
remember that Google
is responsible for
ensuring the physical
and virtual hardware
Google provides
is operating as it should.
Luckily, Google
Cloud Services are
designed to deliver
better security
than many traditional
on-premise solutions.
Because Google runs on
the same infrastructure
they make available
to their customers,
your organization
directly benefits
from these protections.
Google uses a multilayered
defense in depth approach
to security.
Each layer, from physical
data center components
to hardware provenance, secure
boot, secure interservice
communication, secure
data, and protected access
to services from the internet--
each of these has
strict controls
for access and privilege
and is continually evolving.
Let's dive deeper into this.
So how does Google
Cloud really protect
the physical and virtual
hardware provides?
Well, check this out.
As part of their ongoing
efforts to secure the Cloud,
Google Cloud has 850-plus
security engineers,
$200 billion annual security
investment, a 24/7 active
watch, 160-plus
academic research
papers on security,
a bug bounty program,
a penetration testing program.
This shows the level
of investment Google
puts into security.
Google security teams triage,
investigate, and respond
to incidents 24 hours
a day, 365 days a year,
and conduct regular
exercises to measure
and improve security
detection and response.
On the application
side, Google Cloud
provides libraries
and frameworks
that prevent developers
from introducing
certain classes of security
bugs like cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities and web apps.
On Google Cloud, automated tools
like fuzzers, static analysis
tools, and web
security scanners are
used to detect security bugs.
On the access side, Google
makes heavy investment
in protecting Google's
employees' devices
and credentials from
compromise, using technologies
and strict policies for physical
computer data and network
security, access management,
security login, and so much
more.
Ah, that's it.
I know the answer
to Brad's question.
BRAD ACTOR: Hello, detective.
I see you've been quite busy
and solved my little question.
What's really keeping your data
safe once it's in the cloud?
Ah, and you found
the key concept.
Clients secure
their applications,
and Google secures
the infrastructure.
The platform is secure, because
that's Google's responsibility.
And security is
foundational to everything
Google Cloud does, from
designing data centers,
to software, to processes.
But most importantly,
because Google Cloud
runs on the very same
infrastructure it provides
to customers, all
of those protections
can be used by people like
you to protect your business.
Very good, very good.
You've answered
today's question,
but be ready because
next time, I'm
going to make you dig
deeper into the platform
to see exactly how Google
Cloud protects the user's data.
CARTER MORGAN: So
there you have it.
Another episode of
Cloud Security basics.
Next episode, we'll focus on how
Google Cloud protects the data
that lives on their servers.
In the meantime, if you want
to take a deeper dive into how
Google secures
its platform, then
check out the article LinkedIn
the description below.
And stay tuned for the rest of
the Cloud Security Basic Series
because when it
comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]